what's going on guys this is rob and i
have not seen doctor strange two yet so
we are uploading this video before the
movie comes out so that we don't
necessarily do spoilers there will
indefinitely be somebody in the comments
section who will say dude you're
spoiling the movie or something like
that if they do feel free to laugh at
them now here's the thing what this
story does there is a little bit of a
kind of opening right there as there are
stories like i'm stephen strange and i
do stuff that has to do with magic but
the thing about this is that where it
really picks up is basically where
things are popping off in new york and
of course doctor strange ends up showing
up because obviously it has to do with
magic and when this happens he finds a
some boar bastard who basically bonded
himself to the seven sons of cenabus now
under any normal circumstance this
wouldn't really matter because the land
of cenopus right where the seven sons
reside in the celestial concordance is
actually kind of a cool place the sun's
never set and it's like peaceful and
it's harmonious and they really have to
do more with healing than any uh than
anything else but the reason why this
guy's reacting the way that he is is
because something is going on in that
location which is basically wreaking
havoc and so all the pain and torment
that's being experienced in that
dimension is actually being felt by this
guy and that's how stephen strange knows
something's off because if this was any
normal circumstance this would be the
most chill dude ever right like you just
be like be well guys you know he'd be
like a like a hippie in the 60s just
just high on hashish that's what this
guy would be and so knowing that things
are popping off after having bonded
himself to that location that's when
stephen strange one dispels this
connection between the two and then
following that has a little bit of a
meeting with the with the strange
academy now again this is just marvel
kind of bringing in the strange academy
just kind of being like by the way guys
don't forget they exist you know and
like they're still there and still doing
their thing but it's also him kind of
teaching them a little bit about the
nature of the strange academy at least
doctor strange himself now this is just
kind of a rehash for people who never
really read doctor strange before
because the title itself the death of
doctor strange and the fact that it's
timed with the release of the movie will
hopefully bring in people who haven't
necessarily read comics the long and
short of this is all stephen strange
says is look there's a few things you
got to know right as the sorcerer
supreme there is a hierarchy of magic
users in the earthly dimension that
there are some individuals like ileana
rasputin who are the quote unquote
sorcerer supreme of the realm of limbo
and there are people like clea who is
the sorcerer supreme of like the dark
dimension or something like that he's
like but i am the sorcerer supreme of
the earthly realm so think of it in
terms of like a political structure
iliana rasputin is the governor of of
limbo and clea is the governor of the
dark dimension and i am basically above
them all and that's kind of how that
works and he also goes as far as to say
the nature of him being sorcerer supreme
is not a mentally arbitrarily took that
instead the mantle of the sorcerer
supreme is actually a position that's
recognized by the vishanti themselves
and it's always been that way where at
least ever since the vashanti have been
introduced in mobile comics but it's
been that way for decades right like the
ancient one became the sorcerer supreme
because the ancient one was chosen by
the vashanti to be the sorcerer supreme
and what that does is it grants doctor
strange access to magical abilities that
he wouldn't otherwise have if steven
strange was not the sorcerer supreme his
magical powers would be limited to those
of like agatha harkness or ileana
rasputin or something along those lines
but he wouldn't be as powerful as he is
and that's what he says he's like but
rest assured while my job is to
basically be the man on the wall and to
protect the earth from different magical
dimensions that exist out there and
beings that are at all times trying to
conquer us the truth is that somewhere
along the line something will happen and
i will die right and when that happens a
new sorcerer supreme will be chosen by
the vashanti and they'll be able to go
forward from there there's a whole
process behind it he's like but that'll
basically happen and we'll kind of go
from there but one of the things that
stephen strange starts to realize is
that the number of magical beings who
are appearing on earth is actually
starting to pick up at any given point
in time there are just any number of
people from other dimensions who flee
from those dimensions or whatever it is
kind of find their way through the
cracks of the mystical spells that
doctor strange has made and then arrive
on earth usually to escape some you know
just terrible punishment at the hands of
dormammu or satanish or agamon or
something like that the thing about this
is the number of people arriving here
are picking up faster and faster and
that's what it's kind of like okay we
got to figure out what's going on now
before doctor strange can really solve
this mystery what ends up happening is
of course there's a knock at the door
and when he shows up to answer the door
someone and we don't know who absolutely
ensnares him with mystical energy bonds
him to a wall and then in doing so
removes his hands and then kills him and
that's the end of that now the funny
thing about this is that as soon as
doctor strange dies everybody who is in
any form or fashion tied into magic
feels it you get thor you get jericho
drum even reed richards picks up on it
now reed richards doesn't really pick up
on it because of the fact that he has to
do with magic it's because there's all
these dimensional breaches that are
taking place because with the death of
doctor strange also comes the removal of
all the mystical enchantments that have
been placed around the earth to protect
it from these dimensional breaches and
so what ends up happening of course is
as soon as steven strange dies one of
the first people to realize it happened
was baron mordo because remember baron
morta was always the guy trying to take
out steven strange he had kind of like a
vendetta against him and it was always i
will be the one to kill stephen strange
and then i will be the one to replace
him as sorcerer supreme that kind of a
thing and so as a result of that where
initially wong freaks out and attack
stephen strange instead what actually
goes on here is you end up having this
kind of crazy situation where in effect
a kind of mystical portal opens and when
that portal opens up it's classic dr
strange who comes through and he's kind
of like okay what year is it like what's
going on here now the reason why this
this classic version of doctor strange
is here is for a few different reasons
one because there was a safety measure
that doctor strange had put in place in
his younger years he had basically taken
a portion of himself and hidden it away
so that if his physical form was killed
under some circumstance his classic
version could come back figure out who
it was that killed him now it doesn't
mean he'd be here forever and in fact
it's even established right off the bat
this is only really a temporary spell
but it does exist long enough to figure
out who the murderer of doctor strange
is now one of the things that marvel and
jed mckay do here which is kind of
interesting is they nerf the hell out of
the sky they reduce this power in the
extreme one thing to know right in the
the publication history not really just
the in comic history but in the
publication history of doctor strange
when he was originally introduced in
marvel comics the guy could do anything
he wanted to right like literally there
was a spell for everything he's like man
you know i wish i could travel back in
time and you know do something invest in
google or something like that uh well
google didn't really exist then like
invest in colgate or ford back when they
were worth a damn and made vehicles that
matter uh and and so i have a spell for
that right he has a spell that makes him
travel back in time or if he needs to
just arbitrarily overcome some magical
being that's four times more powerful
than he is there's a magical spell that
he can use to achieve that level of
power the guy had no limits he was like
silver aged superman right he got
whatever power he needed at that
particular point in time to come out
victorious in the story it got to the
point where it was just outlandish it
was just it was just man it was it was
goofy to be honest with you man like it
was just it was nonsense the guy would
just overcome the most ridiculous of
odds like literally he broke free of the
the imprisoning bands of the living
tribunal second to god and doctor
strange is like this thing will work and
just breaks out of it and it's like how
can i stop you from destroying the earth
and like that's it and it's just kind of
like all right so the the thing about
this is this version of doctor strange
is nowhere near as powerful as the old
school classic version it's basically
just a younger version of steven strange
himself now of course with everything
popping off the way that it is you do
have zelma that contacted the avengers
of course she is the assistant of of
doctor strange and ultimately just kind
of like hey you know things are popping
off here or what have you the funny
thing here is that when uh captain
america contacts steven strange and
realizes it's not the original not the
the steven strange he knows captain
america kind of takes it to stride he
was like you know what i'll just chalk
it up to the magical stuff that you do
man i don't try to understand it stephen
i don't try to understand the magical
things that you do i just know that
you're capable of doing some stuff and
this is one of those times when you need
you when we need you to do some stuff so
do your stuff and help us overcome
whatever this threat is now the cool
thing about this and this this is one of
the things that i i really find
interesting really find fascinating
about this is that what you have is
basically the arrival of cleo now clea
is a long-standing character in the
doctor strange mythos originally she was
just the girl from the dark dimension
and then she ended up becoming the
girlfriend of steven strange and then
eventually married him and then
essentially things went exactly the way
you would expect them to with a
narcissist like stephen strange and
things went south
but she was the ruler of the dark
dimension at one point in time the point
that i'm making here is depending on
what era you're reading in marvel comics
cleo was broken like back in the day she
was op it was nuts you talk to anybody
who's read like old school doctor
strange stories and they'll say yeah man
like cleo was a hoss way back in the day
uh but this basically takes place at a
point when essentially stephen strange
doesn't hasn't really well he's only met
clea as the girl from the dark dimension
she doesn't become his girlfriend or his
wife yet and so their relationship is
really more of like stephen's passing
interest in her but really nothing more
than that and as soon as that becomes
the case that's when she realizes you're
not stephen strange the at least the
secretary that i know but the other part
of this and the reason why she's here is
because she's basically fleeing and she
says that she's like i'm getting away as
fast as i can they're like what are you
talking about and she's like uh
basically like the mothers right the
three mothers the weird the crown and
the crawling and ultimately she's like
these beings have the ability to follow
people's sense right magical beings and
track them down no matter where they go
and that's the thing once the three
mothers manifest of course like
everybody shows up right you end up
having like beer and mordo who was
already there and he was like uh no i
gotta go and basically bales
alongside his assistant kaiselius and
then you've got the avengers who show up
now the funny thing about this is that
when you're dealing with magical beings
mystical beings and marvel comics it's a
whole different set of rules it's not
like the red skull has teamed up with
hydra yet again and they're going to
attack some place in america and only of
the avengers can save them it's not like
that right this is one of those things
where like you're dealing with a whole
different set of events people with
magical abilities that that literally
augment any existing powers they have or
will simply just give them a whole new
set of powers and that's why when the
three mothers show up here and all the
avengers start facing off against them
they get annihilated right they get
absolutely just crushed with a quickness
i mean thor the whole nine yards these
guys get absolutely wrecked and it's not
even close because at that point the
three sisters i guess apparently they
showed up here just for the purpose of
attacking the avengers and then they
leave they don't really do anything and
in fact they're like you know what we'll
come and grab clea at some future point
in time but it's also because one part
of them knows steven strange as the
sorcerer supreme is not someone you just
trifle with right like you got to kind
of prepare yourself for that little bit
of a battle and so one of the things
that goes on and depending on who you
talk to they may or may not necessarily
agree with this that when it comes to
stephen strange one of the things that's
established is that when his younger
self again with the surgeon background
does the autopsy essentially on his
older self alongside jane foster that he
says that what had happened here is
magic was used to bind uh him his older
self in place and then his hands were
taken and his soul was taken and he says
the reason why this matters is because
it was a magical ritual that whoever it
is that has my hands out there uh it
basically also has my soul with it if my
soul does not pass on to the afterlife
basically travel back into the magical
ether then a new sorcerer supreme cannot
be chosen and because a new sorcerer
supreme cannot be chosen there can be no
sorcerer supreme here now here's the
reason why i say people may or may not
agree with that this directly flies in
the face of the story that basically
dealt with stephen strange losing his
title of sorcerer supreme that if all of
this holds true and that a person is a
sorcerer supreme because they're chosen
by the vashanti there was a story which
is actually how brother voodoo ended up
becoming kind of a mainstay character in
the doctor strange mythos there was a
story where the vashanti enlisted
stephen strange for help with a with a
conflict that they were going against
and steven strange said no so they
stripped him of the mantle of the
sorcerer's supreme along with 80 of his
magic which was basically provided by
the vashanti in doing so they passed the
mantle to brother voodoo to jericho drum
and he ended up becoming dr voodoo and
became the new sorcerer supreme when
that happened of course stephen strange
was kind of there for a while eventually
steven strange got the title back and
went back to being sorcerer supreme but
this story flies in the face of that and
in fact if that story isn't absolute
which it is one of the most significant
stories in the doctor strange mythos
then what's happening here makes no
sense that it wouldn't work this way the
vashanti would just kind of be like okay
we'll just pick a new sorcerer's supreme
and like that would be it now the other
the other big concern here is that he
you know this this classic version of
strange the younger strange says that
his ability to use magical energy the
way that he does is inexorably tied to
his hands whoever it is that's in
possession of his hands likely literally
attached his hands to themselves and now
they can wield all the power that's
available to him uh using him as the
sorcerer supreme right literally using
his soul to become the source for
supreme and so as a result of that it's
basically like somebody put on uh you
know it's pretending to be steven
strange tapping into his power and
basically the vashanti and those guys
out there wouldn't know the difference
because as far as they're aware the soul
of stephen strange is still on earth and
still doing its thing and that's
basically it and so as a result of that
you know he's basically like until we
find my soul and find my hands the earth
may very well be doomed like i cannot do
anything that the sorcerer supreme could
do none of the magical spells that i
cast can keep this self keep this place
safe none of that can go on now the
other thing about this is that all these
different magical beings that exist out
there right umar who's the sister of
dormammu and all that kind of stuff all
those magical warlords have actually
fled to earth and the reason why is
because earth itself has repelled some
pretty heavy hitters galactus dormammu
all those different guys right satanish
and even the living tribunal to a degree
although it was really more the tribunal
walking away but the thing about this is
is they all basically take refuge there
because of how powerful the people on
earth are and the idea is they can all
basically keep those individuals
protected from whoever the three sisters
are along with what is in effect the
peregrine child because you get this
really really cool explanation and this
really really cool discussion here where
you basically end up learning that what
had happened is that somewhere along the
line and we don't really know the
details of how of how it took place but
somewhere along the line the peregrine
child emerged and that is simply just
referred to and really even the three of
the three mothers are referred to as
beings from the outer planes again no
origin is given here we don't know where
they came from we don't know why they do
what they do all we know is that the
peregrine child is literally a consumer
of magic so imagine a peregrine child
basically being a magical version of
galactus essentially that with the uh
with the three mothers they just travel
around from one location to the next
right from like one magical realm to the
next and in turn just consume various
people who are out there various magical
beings the magical energy that abused
them and all that kind of stuff and like
that's it that's all they do again
there's no real motivation for why and
even the story of the three mothers is a
little bit questionable here because
clea goes as far as to say like we don't
necessarily know the origin of the three
mothers but i would go as far as to say
that maybe something had popped off in
their realm but their story is one of
tragedy right and they were probably
ensnared into the service of the
peregrine child but whatever it is
that's the main bad guy in the story
right now and so because of that what
ends up happening is clear basically
casts a spell that involves of some
thing whose name i can't pronounce and
basically it travels around the world
for the purpose of finding the hands of
doctor strange which they ultimately
locate being in the castle of baron
mordo so right off the bat it's just
kind of like okay it makes sense that
baron mordo would do that the guy's
always been a dick but he's always been
the guy who's been gunning for steven
strange always trying to kill him all
that kind of stuff so what we end up
getting are these kind of dual
circumstances happening at the same time
on one circumstance you essentially get
the three mothers that basically show up
to the to the warlord of dagoth right
the one who basically exists out in uh
in in calamesh right that's literally
where his kingdom is just kind of
residing right now uh essentially seven
miles off the coast of cornwall england
and then at the same time you have
steven strange and you have those guys
who basically show up to the castle of
baron mordo and so as these two things
happen simultaneously the three mothers
take out dagoth quite easily right
they're literally able to overcome him
pretty easily and then basically drag
him off to the peregrine child where
he'll ultimately be consumed and then at
the same time steven strange finally
ends up confronting baron mordo and is
like you know what i should have killed
you a long time ago right like well at
least my younger self i should have
killed you shortly after it was revealed
that you were basically a traitor you
know surrounded or at least in the in
the realm of the ancient one right i
should have killed you man that's
basically what i should have done was
taking you out uh and of course baron
mordo basically pops up and while he
does have the eye of agamotto and he
does have the cloak of levitation
ultimately it's one of those things
where you end up having uh having him
just kind of come out and say look what
makes you think that if i were to kill
you that i would lie about it right like
you're stephen strange you're literally
my mortal enemy it would be a source of
pride to destroy you and the reality
here it was it was my mistake earlier
the the ghost thing wasn't looking for
the hands i was looking for the eye of
agamotto i don't know why i kept
thinking it was looking for his hands
i've just been stuck on somebody else
wearing dr strange's hands because it's
weird to me right it's just kind of
strange to me it's cool but it's kind of
strange but regardless of course you
know he's kind of like i would not lie
about killing you steven strange i hate
your guts like i absolutely hate your
guts and i want to be i want to replace
you right i want to end up taking like
taking your place so if anything i would
celebrate the fact that i killed you
everybody in the magical world would
know that i killed you because it would
elevate my stature right if people knew
that i was the one who took you out
people would be like damn this guy's
powerful okay so we won't all bend the
need of aaron mordo per se but we will
recognize that you're very very powerful
right which is kind of enough for him
because the guy's got like a massive ego
but when that happens steven strange is
kind of like you know what you make a
good point you never would have you
never would have lied about it you
wouldn't hide it right you would make it
incredibly evident to everybody that
this is what you've done and so what
ends up happening here is steven strange
basically travels to the domain of umar
right out in antarctica and basically
brings all these different magical
beings together and really just kind of
reveals everything that he had figured
out and so what he says here is if all
you were really looking to do was flee
the three mothers and the peregrine
child you would have just showed up here
by yourself you would have just shown up
here on your own and that would have
been it probably asking for some kind of
a safe harbor in the ways that only you
guys can by basically being jerks and
being rude and so on and so forth but
you brought your entire kingdoms with
you and in order to do that the barrier
created by steven strange had to be
taken down but umar and tiburo and and
so on you guys couldn't simply just show
up here and then basically just consume
this realm or at least you know destroy
me you couldn't do that otherwise you
would risk the wrath of the bashanti and
any number of people that exist out
there all of whom are magic wielders you
would have seen yourselves killed what
you needed was a pawn you needed a
person you can manipulate a person that
you could control that would do the deed
for you and then in doing that you would
be able to enter into this realm so
quite literally you had me killed
because you were trying to get away from
your dimensions and the peregrine child
and three mothers so you could basically
survive not the worst motivation but
you're still dicks for doing it and so
ultimately he's like i have figured out
exactly who the man was or who the
person was that had basically taken me
out the one who had killed me he says i
was told that i exiled a man into the
purple dimension a man who served a dire
enemy of mine the exile to a land of
cruelty and suffering was one thing but
how much more keenly must it have hurt
when this man's master to whom he had
given his unwavering loyalty his blood
and tears and very soul made no effort
to save him would he not wish to hurt
his master the way he had been hurt the
way he had been discarded like a broken
tool of no consequence isn't that right
kaiselius and it turns out kaiselius is
the one who had actually killed steven
strange and that's why he's been wearing
gloves this whole time is to basically
keep his hands hidden right so nobody
would know that he has the hands of
steven strange because inevitably what
would happen is presumably someone
whether it was kaiselius or whoever
would overcome the three sisters and the
peregrine child and that would set the
stage for kaiselius to likely destroy
baron mordo and then in doing so replace
him and then kaiselius would become the
sorcerer supreme but of course in the
midst of all this the three mothers and
the the peregrine child end up showing
up here i feel like i keep saying three
sisters but like the three the three
mothers and the pure green child show up
here and basically a giant battle ends
up unfolding here now the price that's
paid by kaiselius for his actions and
what classic steven strange does is like
look i am a a practitioner of the mystic
arts and ultimately you're using my
hands which i can basically do anything
i want with and he was like i'm not
going to suddenly just let you get away
with my murder instead what he ends up
doing is actually transmogrifying uh
kaiselius to the point where kaiselius
basically ceases to exist and in his
place is basically a resurrected stephen
strange by classic strange using his own
hands to resurrect his present self so
basically the new stephen strange
returns or at least the modern steven
strange ends up returning now it is a
temporary thing it is not going to last
forever right in effect it's just kind
of a basic spell this design to bring
him back because there is a plan that
has to be unfolded here but at the
moment you've got the x-men doing what
they can and the avengers doing what
they can to basically hold off the three
mothers and the peregrine child but
they're not going to last forever and so
ultimately it's one of those things
where classic strange tells modern
strange you have to make sure you stick
to the plan right do not go off course
do not deviate we all know our parts
it's the only way that we can save the
earthly realm and basically defeat the
three mothers and the peregrine child
right it's the only way we can pull all
this off and so what ends up happening
is that in the midst of this battle that
basically dr strange clea tiburo iliana
rasputin and agamon all basically end up
banding together and forming a magical
pentagram and in doing that what it does
is it unites all their powers together
it links all of their powers in effect
it's five sorcerer supremes all
operating together now keep in mind
steven strange is the most powerful of
the sorcerer supremes but they are all
still wildly powerful magical beings in
and of themselves but more so than that
by linking their powers they've become
greater than the sum of their parts and
so in doing so they quite literally end
up basically blasting the the three
mothers now there is a point where the
peregrine child basically ends up
instilling some of its power inside of
them and the reason why this works is
because remember the peregrine child has
basically been consuming magic for eons
so it has a lot more magical energy at
its disposal than the forces of of
steven strange or any of those guys and
so in that moment what ends up happening
is classic strange basically offers
itself as a distraction and races to the
peregrine child and is actually consumed
by it now when the peregrine child looks
at this from the perspective of like
it's consumed stephen strange and his
magical energies that was actually going
on here is it was only the the astral
form of classic strange what it does is
it allows him to enter into the bodily
form of the peregrine child where all
this magical energy resides and much
like a powder keg all it takes is some
kind of an explosion right some kind of
uh something to ignite it and that's
exactly what he does he literally
ignites all this magical energy and in
doing so it basically explodes or
destroys the peregrine child and of
course the three mothers end up going
with it but in effect the day saved i
mean it wraps up pretty quickly it wraps
up pretty fast it is cool to see right
but like they're all basically
incinerated the day is saved and that's
it but following that steven strange of
course has a bit of a meeting the modern
day strange has a bit of a meeting with
clia where he basically confesses how
much he loves her right and the fact
that he was a fool for just like walking
away or letting her leave or anything
along those lines right for letting the
relationship come to an end but he also
says like i can't stay here right like i
cannot stay in this place like this is a
temporary form for me to use after that
like there will be no more sorcerer
supreme on earth and so in effect what
ends up happening is steven strange's
physical form dies but his soul is able
to travel back to the ether and what
marvel has kind of established here is
that with clea being left with the eye
of agamotto and the cloak of levitation
and steven strange's soul being sent to
the being sent back into the ether and
the the vashanti being able to choose a
new source or supreme that in effect
clea ends up becoming the new source for
supreme whether or not it's good or not
i have no idea i haven't read it yet i
don't even know if it's out yet uh but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching the story was okay and i'll
catch you all later peace